Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder haben Sie schon mal erbrochen?
Ja, mir ist übel und ich habe einmal erbrochen.
Wie sagt das Erbrochenes aus?
So gelb, schleimig.
Haben Sie Blutspuren bemerkt?
Nein, habe ich nicht gesehen.
Leiden Sie unter Herzschmerzen oder Brustschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern bemerkt?
Mein Puls ist etwas höher, glaube ich. Aber das liegt glaube ich am Fieber.
Haben Sie keine Enge gefühlt?
Nein.
Sind Ihnen die Husten oder Atemnot aufgefallen?
Haben Sie die Fieber gemessen?
Ja, ich habe Fieber 38,8.
Haben Sie keine Medikamente deswegen?
Nein, bis jetzt nicht. Das Fieber habe ich auch erst vor einigen Stunden gemessen.
Haben Sie die Engebechwerden früher gehabt?
Nein, noch nie.
Haben Sie Schluckbechwerden oder Herzschmerzen?
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Keine Schluckbechwerden.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder Wasserlassen?
Stuhlgang ist in Ordnung. Beim Wasserlassen habe ich bemerkt, dass etwas brennt.
Und ich muss oft Wasser lassen.
Öfters als sonst.
Hat sich der Urin in den letzten Zeiten dunkler?
Der Urin ist nicht so klar. Sonst ist der Urin immer sehr klar.
Und jetzt ist er etwas trübel.
Trübel?
Ja.
Meinten Sie Eitzig oder?
Er ist wie ein Schleier auf dem Urin. Er ist nicht so klar.
Sonst ist der Urin sehr klar und jetzt ist er eher so milchig.
Haben Sie noch Ländenschmerzen?
Hauptsächlich ist der Schmerz hinten im Rücken.
Auf der rechten Seite.
Und Bauch auch.
Bauch auch ein bisschen. Aber mehr im Rücken.
Wie schlafen Sie in der letzten Zeit? Haben Sie Schlafprobleme?
Normalerweise schlafe ich gut. Aber die letzte Nacht habe ich nicht gut geschlafen.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden.
Ist Ihnen schwindelig?
Nein, ist nicht schwindelig.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Normalerweise ist er gut. Aber seit zwei Tagen nicht so gut.
Mir ist ja übel und ich habe ja auch erbrochen. Da habe ich nicht so guten Appetit.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit ungewohnt ab oder zugenommen?
Nein, ich habe mein Gewicht gehalten.
Waren Sie deswegen bei einem anderen Arzt?
Nein.
Sie sind direkt zu uns gekommen.
Leiden Sie ein chronischer Kranken?
Ja, seit 20 Jahren habe ich eine Schilddrüsenunterfunktion.
Da wurde mir gesagt, dass das eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung sei.
Da muss ich auch ein Medikament nehmen.
Welches Medikament nehmen Sie ein?
Das Mittel heißt Eutyrox.
Erinnern Sie sich die Name Ihrer Krankheit?
Man hat gesagt, das sei eine chronische Schilddrüsenentzündung.
Man hat ja gesagt, das sei eine Autoimmunerkrankung.
Mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie Eutyrox einnehmen.
Wie viel Milgramm?
Dahinter steht 50.
Und da nehme ich eine Morgens.
Und was steht bei Ihnen?
Noch andere Erkrankungen?
Ja, ich habe noch eine Allergie auf Hausstaubmilbe.
Wie auch ich soll es sich?
Und auch Pollenallergie, Gräser und Getreide.
Da habe ich schon zweimal eine Spritzenbehandlung gemacht.
Eine Desensibilisierung.
Das hat etwas geholfen, aber noch nicht so richtig.
Wie äußert sich die Allergie?
Hauptsächlich an den Schleimhäuten.
Nase, Augen, die Augen tränen.
Und im Sommer, wenn Getreide und Gräser stark sind, habe ich auch manchmal Asthma.
Und dann muss ich auch in dieser Zeit, das sind so 2-3 Wochen,
nehme ich dann auch zwei verschiedene Asthmaspres.
Wie heisst dieses Medikament?
Das eine Asthma-Spray heisst BUDES.
Und das andere Salbutamol.
Bei Bedarf?
Ja, BUDES nehme ich dann in dieser Zeit regelmäßig.
Für 2-3 Wochen und Salbutamol bei Bedarf.
Gibt es bei Ihnen noch andere Erkrankungen, von denen ich wissen sollte?
Nein, sonst geht es mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, im Alter von 12 Jahren wurde ich an der rechten Leiste, am Leistenbruch operiert.
Da war ich 12 Jahre alt.
Die Operation komplikation?
Die war in Ordnung, ja.
Vor 11 Jahren hatte ich einen Kaiserschnitt bei der Geburt meiner Tochter.
Das war vor 11 Jahren.
Und vor 5 Jahren hatte ich mir den linken Unterarm, beide Knochen, gebrochen.
Beide Knochen am Unterarm.
Ich glaube das ist Elle und Speiche.
Da habe ich gebrochen gehabt durch einen Sturz mit dem Fahrrad und das musste operiert werden.
Und beide Handgelenke haben Sie gesagt, oder?
Nein, links. Nur der linke Unterarm.
Aber beide Knochen.
Und wurde bei Ihnen eine Kaiserschnitt durchgeführt?
Kaiserschnitt vor 11 Jahren.
Meinten Sie, die Tochter geboren hat?
Nein, nur Kaiserschnitt, für die Geburt.
Ja, und gibt es in Ihrer Familie wichtige und chronische Erkrankungen?
Also mein Vater ist 68 Jahre alt.
Und seit 5 Jahren muss er 3 Mal pro Woche zur Blutwäsche.
Weil er eine schlechte Nierenfunktion hat.
Blut? Was?
Wäsche. Das wird das Blut gereinigt, weil die Nieren nicht mehr verarbeitet.
Seit 5 Jahren?
Ja.
Wegen der Niereninsuffizienz, oder?
Also schlechte funktionierende Nieren, ja.
Und die Mutter ist noch am Leben?
Die Mutter ist auch 68 Jahre alt.
Und bei der Mutter wurde vor 2 Jahren ein Krebs am Enddarm festgestellt.
Also am Enddarm.
Ein Krebs, der musste operiert werden.
Das war wohl sehr schwierig, aber es ist gut geworden und sie fühlt sich im Augenblick wohl.
Das geht.
Und haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, einen Bruder.
Der hatte als Kind einen Wasserkopf.
Und dann bekam er ein kleines Röhrchen, einen Schlauch vom Kopf in den Bauchraum.
Und dann wurde das überflüssige Wasser da in den Bauchraum abgeleitet.
Und das hat wohl gut funktioniert.
Und er hat jetzt seit einigen Jahren eine chronische Darmentzündung.
Ich weiß aber nicht genau den Namen.
Und manchmal hat er sehr viel Blut im Stuhl.
Muss dann auch immer dementsprechende Medikamente nehmen.
Wie alt ist er?
Der Bruder ist 36.
36.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Und was machen Sie für die Pflicht?
Wir wohnen zusammen mit meinem Mann und meiner Tochter.
Sie haben noch eine Tochter?
Eine Tochter, ja. 11 Jahre alt.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja.
Und was machen Sie für die Pflicht?
Ich bin Verkäuferin in einem Schuhgeschäft.
Schuhgeschäft.
Für Schuhe.
Schuhe.
Haben Sie Haustiere?
Nein, keine Haustiere.
Waren Sie in der letzten Zeit im Ausland?
Ich war in Italien.
Im Herbst, im Oktober war ich eine Woche in Italien, in Rom.
Aber sonst war ich nicht im Ausland.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Beschwerden nach der Reise gehabt?
Nein.
Und ist Ihre Regelblutung regelmäßig?
Ja, zuletzt vor zwei Wochen.
Gibt es eine Möglichkeit für Schwänke?
Das glaube ich nicht.
Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Und Frau Osteman, Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie häufig Wasser lassen müssen.
Und wie häufig müssen Sie am Tag Wasser lassen?
Also pro Stunde mindestens einmal.
Manchmal zweimal.
Wann treten diese Beschwerden besonders auf? In der Nacht oder?
Nein, auch tagsüber.
Das ist jetzt erst seit zwei Tagen.
Vorher war das nicht.
Vorher war alles in Ordnung.
Und Sie haben keine Blutverspuren im Urin bemerkt, oder?
Habe ich nicht gesehen. Das bin ich auch nicht gesehen.
Und Leidungsunter-Schweißausbrüche, oder?
Ja, ich habe in der letzten Nacht sehr stark geschwitzt.
Besonders in der Nacht.
Ja, ich habe meine alle Tage gestellt.
Möchten Sie etwas dazu sagen über Ihre Beschwerden?
Ja, was kann ich haben? Was kann das sein?
Ja, Frau Osteman, das ist so, um die richtige Diagnose zu stellen.
Aber natürlich habe ich, oder vermute, wegen Ihrer Beschwerden eine Diagnose.
Aber um die Diagnose zu bestätigen, müssen wir einige Unterzüge durchführen.
Und Blut abnehmen.
Nach den Ergebnissen können wir nochmal über Ihre Beschwerden und Krankheitserwähren sprechen.
Okay, das können wir gut machen.
Gut, danke. Dann haben Sie jetzt erst mal einige Minuten Zeit.
Denken Sie an die Übersetzung der Patientensprache in Fachsprache.
Und Kolleginnen und Kollegen, die zugeschaut zugehört haben, haben vielleicht doch Ergänzungsfragen.
Oder sind alle wesentlichen Fragen gestellt worden, die wichtig sind für eine Diagnosefindung?
Sie können das fragen.
Sie haben gesagt, dass Sie am rechten Bauch leichte Schmerzen haben.
Aber wo können Sie Ihre Schmerzen genau localisiert?
Am Oberbauch oder?
Am Bauch sind sie mehr so in der Mitte.
Aber der Hauptschmerz ist am Rücken rechts.
Rechts am Rücken, da am Ende, wo die Rippen sind.
Wo die Rippen zu Ende sind, da unten.
Ja, danke schön.
Und noch eine letzte Frage.
Haben Sie Veränderungen an Ihrem Gesicht oder Ihren Körper bemerkt?
Ich meinte die Farbeveränderungen.
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Vielleicht sind Sie gelblich geworden.
Nein.
Danke schön.
Gut, dann lasse ich Sie jetzt zwei, drei Minuten in Ruhe.
Dann können Sie sich konzentrieren.
Ich komme gleich wieder zu Ihnen.
Und dann stellen Sie die Patientin bitte vor.
Danke, bis gleich.
Danke schön.
Ja, vergessen.
Ich bin mal einstellen.
Ich wollte fragen, dass Ihre Schmerzen schon schlimmer geworden sind.
Aber ja, ich kann so weiterführen.
Und guten Tag Herr Chefarzt.
Ich möchte Ihnen heute unsere neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Wenn Sie seit haben, kann ich anfangen.
Ja, habe ich.
Es handelt sich um Frau Anna Ostermann.
Sie ist 38 Jahre alt.
26. April 1987 geboren.
1987.
Ich freue mich gleich auf Ihre Schmerzen.
Nein, das ist falsch.
Ich habe das nicht bemerkt.
Okay.
Ich habe mir das gehört.
Sie ist 1,70 Meter groß und 64 Kilogramm schwer.
Okay.
Und der Patientin stellte sich seit zwei Tagen bestehende, dauerhafte, dumpfartige und langsam aufgetretene Rückenschmerzen am rechten Bereich.
Und leichte ...
Sie können sagen, dass die Patientin sich seit zwei Tagen bestehende, dumpfer und drückende Dorsalenschmerzen und auch im linken Mittelbauch befindliche Schmerzen vorstellte.
Und die Schmerzintensität wurde mit vier von zehn auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Es gab keine Auslöse für die Schmerzen.
Und die Patientin hat keine Medikamente dagegen eingenommen.
Die Fragen nach Lysbne und Palpitationsschmerzen wurden verneint.
Darüberhin berichtete sie über Insomni und Neuse und Einmaliges.
Einmaliges, Gäbliches und Schleimiges erbrochen.
Oder Emesis, einmalige Emesis.
Emesis.
Sie klagt über Inapetans, Dysurie und Polycysturie sowie erhöhte Fieber mit 38,8.
Sagen Sie ruhig, dann bestehen es febrile Temperaturen von 38,8.
Wissen Sie, wo die Patientin das gemessen hat?
Nein, ich habe nicht gefragt.
Während der Untersuchung kann ich nachfragen.
Sollten Sie möglichst immer fragen, wo, in diesem Falle im Mund, also oral gemessen.
38,8, ein wichtiger Hinweis.
Fiebrile Temperaturen.
Ich versuche kurz zu wiederholen, was Sie mir berichtet haben.
Eine 38-jährige Patientin, seit zwei Tagen Beschwerden, Fatigue, rechtsdorsale Schmerzen,
die auch im rechten Mittelbauch sind, aber hauptsächlich Dorsal.
Schmerzgrad um 4.
Der Schmerz ist dumpf und bohrend beschrieben.
Es besteht Nausea und einmalige Emesis.
Das Erbrochene ist gelblich schleimig, kein Blut.
Es besteht eine Dysurie und Polycysturie.
Ja, gut.
Ja, fahren Sie bitte fort.
Anfängerkrankungen sind bei ihr seit 20 Jahren eine Hypothyroise bekannt.
Sie leidet an Allergien gegen Hashtabmelben, Greise und Polarallergien.
Okay.
Ja, und die Hypothyroose, da hat die Patientin noch was zu gesagt, was das sein kann eventuell.
Ja, das kann eine Hashimoto-Trioditis sein.
Sie hat gesagt, dass diese Erkrankung Oto-Imin ist.
Ja, also wahrscheinlich eine Hashimoto-Trioditis.
Kann man sagen wahrscheinlich.
Wahrscheinlich, ja.
Wir wissen es nicht genau, aber wahrscheinlich.
Gut, dann gerne wissen, Hashtabmelbenallergien, okay, und Pollen auf Gräser und Getreide.
Wird das behandelt?
Sie würde mit Hypersensibilierungstherapie behandelt.
Sie hat schon dreimal erhalten.
Ja, erhalten, ja.
Diese Allergie äußern sich mit Renitis und Asthma.
In Besuch auf die Medikamente nimmt sie regelmäßig Ötrok, 50 mg morgens und Budes und Salbutamol-Spray bei Bedarf ein.
Okay.
Denken Sie bitte dran, Schildrösenpräparate werden in Mikrogramm dosiert.
Kein Milligramm, ja.
Sie nehmen Oto-Rox 50 Mikrogramm.
Gut, das sind die Medikamente, die Sie mit den Schildrösenpräparaten ausprobieren.
Das ist die Medikament, die Sie mit den Schildrösenpräparaten ausprobieren.
Oto-Rox 50 Mikrogramm, ja.
Gut, das sind die Medikamente.
Ich glaube, sie hat gesagt, Budes nimmt sie, wenn die Gräser sind, 2-3 Wochen lang, 2-mal am Tag und Salbutamol bei Bedarf.
Gut, ist die Patientin schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, sie ist im Alter von 12 wegen Leistenhernie rechts operiert worden.
Leistenhernie ist teilweise medizinisch und teilweise Patientensprache. Kennen Sie Leistenhernie?
Hernie Inguinalis natürlich.
Inguinalis, ja. Inguinalhernie. Und die Operation ist dann eine Herniotomie.
Herniotomie.
Okay, das war im Alter von 12 Jahren. Und was gab es noch für Operationen?
Sie hat sich vor 11 Jahren eine Sektio cesaria untersogen.
Und sie ist vor 5 Jahren nach einem Fahrradunfall gegen Unterarmfraktur links operiert worden.
Was war die Fraktur? Woraus bestand die Fraktur? Welche Knochen?
Die beiden Knochen, L und die Radius- und Ulnafraktur.
Eine linksseitige Ulna- und Radiusfraktur musste operiert werden.
Okay, mehr müssen wir gar nicht wissen und sagen, die Patientin hat das ja nur berichtet.
Wir wissen gar nicht, was da für eine Technik oder was gemacht wurde. Aber nur die Angabe erst mal.
Gut, das waren die Operationen. Raucht die Patientin?
Also ich habe das vergessen.
Haben Sie nicht gefragt. Die Patientin ist nicht Raucherin. Und sie trinkt 2 Gläser Wein pro Woche.
2 Gläser.
Gut, gibt es Auffälligkeiten in der Familie?
Ja, Familie an einem Nächsten ist bestätigt bei Vater.
Eine, die liest vielleicht seit 5 Jahren.
Okay. Und die Mutter...
Wie alt ist der Vater? Entschuldigung?
68 Jahre alt ist er. Und die Mutter ist noch 68 Jahre alt und leidet an Enddarmkrebs und Kolonkarzinom.
Wie ist die anatomische Bezeichnung für den Enddarm? Das letzte Stück des Darmes vor dem Sphincter.
Das was man mit einem Finger palpieren kann. Was machen Sie da? Welches Organ palpieren Sie?
Das ist das Rektum.
Also die Patientin hatte vor 2 Jahren wohl ein Rektumkarzinom.
Und er müsste operiert werden.
Okay.
Und sie hat einen Bruder. Der Bruder hat in der Kindheit Wasser gepustet.
Ah, da gibt es einen Fachausdruck. Kennen Sie das?
Nein, ich weiß das nicht.
Da unten steht es Hydrocephalus.
Hydrocephalus ist der Wasserkopf. Und da wird eine Drainage gelegt. Oft dann so getan in den Bauchraum.
Und das wird dann ein Schand, ein peritonealer Schand, der wird dann gelegt und dann wird es entlastet.
Was hat der Bruder denn noch?
Der Bruder leidet noch einen kurzen Darmentzünd.
Welche zwei Erkrankungen kommen in Frage?
Das kann Crohn und Ulcerativkulid sein.
Das können es sein.
Entheritis regionalis oder so.
Manchmal hat er wohl, wie die Patientin sagte, stark blutige Stühle.
Das ist erst mal nur eine Angabe. Wir haben die genauen Diagnosen noch nicht vom Bruder.
Im Rahmen der Familienanalyse.
Das ist meine Frage. Spannende Frage. Was ist Ihre Verdachtstheatose?
Die Anamnitsischen angeben dort am engsten auf eine Nephrolithiasis.
Da sie Polakisirui, Disirui und Fieber und ja, Fatigue.
In der Nephrolithiasis kann es eher einen Kolikartigen Schmerz geben.
Wenn es eine Urethakolik ist oder so etwas. Das macht ja oft Kolikschmerzen, die dann auch stärker sind als vier.
Ist das die Angabe?
Ja, eher eine Itis, eine Entzündung.
Das ist fast wie eine Pyelonephritis.
Weil der Hauptstärz ist rechts dorsal im Rücken.
Wenn Sie die Patientin untersuchen gleich und Sie machen eine Perkussion und klopfen das Nierenlager,
dann wird das sehr schmerzhaft sein. Das ist ein klopfschmerzhaftes Nierenlager.
Die Patientin wird sagen, bitte nicht mehr, stopp.
Das spricht schon für eine Pyelonephritis. Wir haben die Disirui, wir haben die Polakisirui, wir haben Fieber.
Eine Nephrolithiasis macht nicht immer Fieber. Es führt zu einem starken Staunen.
Ich bin kein Urologe. Vielleicht gibt es viele Urologen bei den Kollegen.
Das weiss eine Entzündung.
Fragen Sie bitte noch Differentialdiagnose.
Ja, Differentialdiagnose kommen in Nephrolithiasis und Apendicitis.
Ich würde immer noch an ein Organ denken, an das man dann oft nicht denkt.
Apendicitis.
Apendicitis, das würde ich immer noch ins Spiel bringen.
Eine Apendicitis, die atypisch ist vielleicht vom Schmerzcharakter.
In die Mitte hat sie Schmerzen, leichte Schmerzen.
Das kann sein. Aber Sie werden ja allein aufgrund der körperlichen Untersuchung schon sehr viele neue Zusatzinformationen bekommen.
Und können dann bestimmte Dinge vielleicht schon eher ausschließen oder nicht.
Natürlich auch Laboruntersuchung, Urinuntersuchung und dann wird das den Gegner.
Vielen Dank. Ich habe Sie gut verstanden. Sie wissen auch viele Fachbegriffe, sehr viele.
Sie setzen sich auch gut ein. Im Anfang, das machen Sie jetzt wieder.
Wenn Sie die Vorstellung gemacht haben, haben Sie im Anfang immer so gemacht.
Stimmt Sie den Mund oder die Hände, versuchen Sie das möglichst nicht zu tun.
Aber ich weiß, das ist der Stress.
Aber das ist so. Das ist meine Beobachtung.
Normalerweise, wenn ich unter Schützres bin, sage ich immer, das ist meine Aneurätik.
Sie haben sehr oft die Finger, aber das ist ein Ausdruck von einem Stress.
Es geht mir wahrscheinlich genauso. Aber ich habe es beobachtet.
Aber ich finde, Sie haben das sehr gut gemacht. Sie haben das auch sehr systematisch gemacht.
Haben Sie dann bald Prüfung?
Ja, nächste Woche.
Wo? Am 18. April.
Und wo ist das? Im München.
Ok, dann wünsche ich Ihnen alles Gute für die Prüfung.
Vielen Dank.
Ich bin nicht so gut. Ich fühle mich nicht gut verbereitet, aber ich möchte probieren.
Aber ich habe ein gutes Gefühl. Ich probiere Sie das.
Danke schön. Vielen Dank.
Ich sage noch mal kurz, wir können gerne nächste Woche Donnerstag wieder machen.
Und dann wünsche ich Ihnen jetzt erstmal einen schönen Abend.
Schönen Abend. Tschüss.